disons que les médecins dans le temps
tout au moins les premiers médecins euh
qui ont eu l'occasion de me voir dans
mon enfance disons me condamner à mort
de cinq ans cinq ans
monsieur Lecoeuvre archeviste à Roubaix
dans un journal régional s'est illustré
à mettre prise dans les jeux
radiophoniques et télévisés pour les
animateurs c'est la bête noire il a
réponse à tout mais ce qu'il ne savent
pas les animateurs c'est que Monsieur
Lecoeuvre a une méthode infaillible pour
gagner ce secret étonnant qu'il a
accepté de nous dévoiler et d'ordre
alimentaire
je le mange que quatre aliments trois
solides un liquide qui sont le pain le
beurre le chocolat le liquide est un
labiaire depuis 48 ans vous ne mangez
que ces trois éléments
jamais autre chose vous ne pouvez pas
imaginer autre chose je suis né dans une
alimentation générale une épicerie
j'étais bien placé justement pour disons
pour avoir le l'embarras du choix dans
l'alimentation bien bon ben on m'a tout
offert
et je rien n'est passé au niveau du
palais si vous voulez au niveau du goût
rien n'est passé que ces aliments que
vous voyez devant moi mais ça doit être
lassant alors pas pour moi par jour
disons que je mange je sais pas où enfin
vivant 4 enfin deux fois ça de chocolat
quoi 4 règles de chocolat
même pas 100 g de beurre sur ces sirop
de pince on sait pas c'est tout ça ne
demande pas de sortir d'une grande école
vous savez comprendre que deux tranches
de pain voilà on prend un couteau
on meurt une surface
voilà
je dirais même que dans la pratique je
mange jamais deux tranches sur l'autre
d'ailleurs en fait c'est un sandwich
un ministre en lui et puis alors un
morceau de chocolat
un morceau de pain
un morceau de chocolat un morceau de
pain trois fois par jour c'est à peu
près le même geste c'est pas trois fois
par jour le même geste
ces trois fois par jour si on veut le
même geste mais multiplier par 365 jours
multiplié par 48 ans jamais vous ne
faites d'excès jamais de chocolat aux
noisettes parce qu'il y a du chocolat
aux noisette ici je vous ai dit que je
mangeais 4 aliments du pain grive beurre
du chocolat et je buvais de la bière
noisette les médecins qu'en pensent-ils
de votre cas
disons que les médecins dans le temps
tout au moins les premiers médecins
qui ont l'occasion de voir dans mon
enfance disons me condamner à mort de
cinq ans cinq ans alors vous croquez à
boudin mais non faut le mettre dedans
comme les gosses théoriquement mais vous
me laissez mes pains au chocolat
une fois le chocolat une fois le pain
une fois le chocolat ça fait bébé ça
fait peut-être bébé
vous avez son budget au point de vue
alimentation c'est très difficile parce
que c'est un budget qui est confondu
avec celui de mon épouse mais à nous
deux ça nous fait du 500 francs par mois
à peu près
pour l'ensemble de nos dépenses
alimentaires uniquement 500 francs
plutôt au moins le plus pour mes 1m50 3
je fais 51 kg et ça fait pratiquement
depuis 10-15 ans que je vais pas bougé
[Musique]
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer la vie de
Monsieur le keuvre n'est pas toujours
rose pour le prouver nous l'avons invité
au restaurant qu'il appelle lui un lieu
de débauche
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu de près des
homards
de voir manger les autres alors c'est la
première fois que vous venez dans un
restaurant monsieur lequel exactement je
ne connais ni l'usage de la fourchette
ni l'usage de la cuillère ni même
l'usage de l'assiette le maître d'hôtel
a bien pris notre commande mais en
cuisine
et pour suivre à la deux une tablette de
chocolat et deux tartines beurrées non
mais ça va pas non
il faut avouer qu'à l'heure du déjeuner
les épiceries sont fermées alors
Monsieur Lecoeuvre a dû se priver de
repas mais il a pu se rattraper en nous
quittant car il a réintégré son poste au
journal Nord éclair éclair au chocolat
bien sûr
[Rires]
[Musique]